The main concept of HTTP is that
clients tell servers what they
want by using an HTTP verb,
also know as an HTTP method.
There are nine HTTP verbs in
the current HTTP specification.
The two most commonly used methods for
websites though, are GET and POST.
A GET request can be thought of
as the client telling the server,
get me some information that you have.
Or, a POST can be thought
of as the client saying,
I want to modify some
information that you have.
GETs are sometimes called safe methods,
since they are only used to retrieve
existing data from the database,
whereas POSTs call for data to be added,
removed, or changed on a server.
We know that the client prefixes
requests to the server with HTTP verbs.
So, how does the server reply?
Status codes are the server's
reply to a client as to
what happened after a specific request.
In addition to a status code,
a server can also supply any requested
resources the client requested,
such as HTML, CSS and JavaScript, and
media files such as images and audio.
Some common response codes are 200,
which indicates a successful GET
request, 301, which is a successful
post request, and 404, which indicates
that we were looking for a file on the
server, and the server couldn't find it.
In the next section, we'll put all
of these concepts together as we
create our own web server in Python.